I don't believe I've had him on this
show yet and I've enjoyed his work not
only as a head coach in the NBA for 12
seasons but also his work on television
and he's joining us from our friends at
Turner Sports which has a huge double
dip tonight a huge doubleheader starting
with the so-called game of the year to
date Lakers in Bucks he is Stan Van
Gundy how are you Stan
I'm doing great glad to be with where do
you stand on the conversation
everybody's having that this is a
preview for the Larry O'Brien trophy
next June what do you think well I think
it's certainly possible
you know Milwaukee is sort of well ahead
of the pack in the East I don't see a
true second contender there I see a big
group below them but you know they're
certainly in a class by themselves and I
think it's the Lakers and the Clippers
right now that looked like the two teams
to beat in the West so I would say that
if you could could put money on this
being an NBA Finals you're probably
about 50/50 having a chance so a pretty
darn good chance done let me ask you the
question we were just debating here on
this show if I told you only one of
these teams would be in the finals which
one would you choose is the most likely
Milwaukee just because I think you know
they're that far ahead of everybody in
the East based on what we said this far
far but but in the West I think as good
as the Lakers have been you can see the
Clippers at full strength
having a very good chance of beating
them so I would say the buck and then
you got the Clippers in the and the
Rockets in the second part of the
doubleheader tonight on TNT let's focus
on the first game first how does it
match up bust out there the X's and O's
grease board here Stan I think it
matches up really well like these teams
are a little bit different stylistically
but they're both among the best teams in
the league at both ends of the floor
they both have great size I think that
LA relies a little bit less on the
three-point shot then Milwaukee does
Milwaukee shoots
a lot of them neither team has shot the
three very well this year but both teams
rely on guys getting in the paint LeBron
James Anthony Davis to a lesser degree
and Yanis uncut equipo so look I mean I
think it's going to be a great battle I
think it'll be decided on the game in
transition where Milwaukee has been
better than the Lakers the Lakers only
weakness defensively has been their
transition defense and I think it'll be
decided as a lot of games are on
turnovers and so transition and
turnovers I think decide it but it'll be
a great battle let's say we get into
half-court set though who guards who
what do you think Stan guards who I
think that we will see you know Yanis on
Anthony Davis I don't really think that
Milwaukee has a lot of you know options
there I think Wes Matthews guards LeBron
James just to give a little bit of a
strength matchup at the other end of the
floor I think it'll be a little bit
interesting I think you'll still see
Anthony Davis on on Yanis but you don't
have to they're they could put you know
that a lot of teams will put their
Center on honest and just backup but he
has been shooting the ball a little bit
better I think it'll be Anthony Davis
you think it'll be a ad when it comes
down to it why are the Lakers twenty
four and four I mean we all knew they
would be pretty darn good but what other
I guess buttons got pushed by pálinka
and the rest of the crew
whether it's Vogel as well in game what
are you seeing as to why the Lakers are
maybe even better than folks believed
Stan Van Gundy well I think rich because
they they've done a good job number one
of roster construction they got the
right kinds of people around LeBron
James and in Anthony Davis I mean a real
underrated thing was what they did with
their two centers with Dwight Howard and
JaVale McGee we were playing a combined
of about 36 minutes a game so they're
really just taking one position it's not
really starter and backup because
Anthony Davis play some minutes there
- but in those 36 minutes they're
getting about 14 points 14 rebounds and
four blocks at a very high shooting
percentage so you know they're getting
great production out of that spot then
they've gone out and put perimeter
players around LeBron who are all
capable of shooting the three Danny
Green Kentavious caldwell-pope Troy
Daniels rouser on Rondo who shot the
ball extremely well Avery Bradley but
the other part of that is all of those
guys except for Troy Daniels are
exceptional defenders so I give them an
A on their roster construction but Ben
Frank Vogel I think did a great job in
putting it all together because he knew
that the offense would take a little bit
of time bunch of new guys trying to
figure it out so he really went in from
day one of the training camp and
emphasized offense and they came out of
the gates as an elite defensive team
their half court often struggled in a
big way early on but their defense was
so good and help them create enough
offense in transition that they were
able to get by and then their half-court
offense caught up playing through
Anthony Davis and LeBron so now they're
elite on both ends of the floor so both
their front office and their coaching
staffs have done great job the talent is
there I don't see any reason that this
team will experience any significant
slippage over the course of the year
other than obviously a major injury to
Anthony Davis or Braun Stan Van Gundy
Turner Sports right here on the Rich
Eisen show you mentioned how Clippers
full strength can give the Lakers more
than they can handle potentially why do
you say that I think I can figure it out
but I want you to lay it out for me well
I think again it's a I'm gonna give them
a little bit of an edge in terms of
their half-court offense because they
have both of their stars our shot
creators not just shot makers Paul
George can get his own shot he can get
some shots for teammates Kawhi Leonard
obviously can do both and LeBron can but
Anthony Davis is primarily a shot maker
he'll pass when he
double-teamed in the post but he's not
going to put it on the floor and make a
lot of plays so I'll give him a slight
edge with their two stars but the
biggest edge to me that the Clippers
have is when you turn to the bench
I like the Lakers depth don't get me
wrong rich I really liked it but Lou
Williams and montrezl harrell I mean you
know that they're gonna have two guys
average over 18 points a game coming off
their bench and then they're both in
there finishing lineup so there's a lot
of weapons there that the defensive end
both teams are really good the Lakers
I'd give an edge inside with their sides
with Anthony Davis
JaVale McGee Dwight Howard and their
shot blocking but I think the Clippers
defense on the perimeter is even better
than the Lakers and the Lakers is pretty
good but with Pat Beverley
and Kawhi Leonard and Paul George that's
as good a perimeter defensively as we've
seen in the since I came into the league
anyway in the midnight well it's Stan
Van Gundy here on the Rich Eisen show in
your 12 years as being a head coach you
had some great podium games Stan you had
some great press conference game man I
mean the you didn't mince any words and
then if you needed to get passive
aggressive you got passive aggressive so
I want you to translate these comments
for me from Doc Rivers in response to
the LeBron James talking about his
obligation is to play if I'm healthy I'm
gonna play if the coach sits me up and
I'm not healthy talking about load
management that was brought up to Doc
Rivers quote it's our philosophy I don't
know what theirs are referring to the
Lakers I think theirs is whatever LeBron
says it is to be honest to stand your
thoughts well I think he is right in
that regard I think particularly as a
veteran player rich that's had as much
success as bran you're certainly going
to listen to him and if he feels he
needs rest
you're gonna give it to him primarily
because LeBrons never been a guy that
has just wanted to rest for no reason no
I know but you don't you don't think doc
is basically saying hey LeBron's running
the team that's what I'm saying you
didn't pick up
there Stan he's not running the team
anymore than Kawhi Leonard is running
the Clippers you know and if you want to
put it that way yeah Kawhi Leonard is
making a lot of decisions on when he
plays and doesn't play Kawhi Leonard
made his decision to come there only
after they were able to engineer a trade
for Paul George
so look players have been empowered in
this era and for anybody to act like
somebody else's star player is running
the team but their's isn't I don't think
that that's realistic or fair I think
both of those guys have a huge say in
what's going on with their organization
I think their record of success winning
championships and leading teams has
given the right giving them the right to
do that I don't think there's anything
inappropriate going on with either team
I still think Frank Vogel is coaching
the Los Angeles Lakers I don't think
it's LeBron coach of that team and I
still think it's Doc Rivers coaching the
LA Clippers I think Doc got a little
sensitive about somebody talking about
the load management mom but I don't
think he needs to be yeah they're trying
to manage a chronic injury situation
with Kawhi Leonard and keep him healthy
for the playoffs LeBron doesn't feel
like he needs met for him neither one of
them's in the wrong here what if you
however a coach of a team that shares a
building with another organization that
the entire city is talking about and
maybe you want to lob a little bit of a
verbal grenade and stir things up Stan
do you think that's maybe one who's
doing right there - a little bit I think
there's always been and always will be a
little bit of an inferiority complex on
the side on the you know part of the
Clippers not because they're inferior on
the court but simply because as you
referenced rich I mean it's going to be
a long long time before in terms of
basketball that will be anything other
than a Laker town it's just like in New
York Brooklyn's a far better franchise
right now that is a New York Knicks town
we all know that and it's the same thing
there so if you're the other team in
those cities yeah you're a little bit
sensitive to that and you know LeBron
sort of threw a little bit
barb at the Clippers and at Kauai baby
doc Zelda was directed at him with the
load management and so and so doc fired
back look we love these things we should
this is what no we should this is what
the rivalries are all about we don't
want these teams to play to nice do we
rich I mean we want to think there's
some bad blood there and I think there
is you're in the same city fighting for
the same fanbase yeah things should be
pretty and they shouldn't be nice and I
think it's already turning that way in
LA and that's why in addition for the
talent there that's why this is going to
be a great great ride yeah and then you
got harden in Westbrook in town in Los
Angeles tonight Westbrook you know
obviously ladies college ball here it's
gonna be a great doubleheader on TNT
tonight before I let you go Stan Van
Gundy give me your favorite David Stern
story as we are only hoping for the best
for Hamels lousy convalesces you got a
good one Stan well you know what I have
is is my own stories and you know David
didn't like me very much a lot of the
things that I a lot of the things that I
said but I think where he really got me
is at the time the Arab Spring was going
on rich I compared David Stern for the
dictators in the Middle East for terms
of his inability to tolerate dissent and
for some reason which he didn't
appreciate voices displeasure with you
Stan well interesting David is a very
very smart guy and so to come out and
find me for that comment saying that he
doesn't tolerate dissent I think he
realized would have played in to my
favor yes you know and so David went to
our to our team owners and basically
told them that he had had it with me and
I was gonna knock it off and he imposed
some discipline on the team but never
publicized it so as not to play in my
hand yes and you know it worked I mean
when you're older when your boss tells
you to
get off you knock it off nothing ever
came out publicly David just let you
know let my comment stand without a
rebuttal
and so David took the high ground in the
whole thing which basically was enough
to certainly refute what I was saying
and at the same time discipline to me
enough to get me to stop I will say even
though I disagreed with the guy like a
lot and didn't like him all the time
that was a very savvy move on his part
well so you're basically saying you
added a couple dimensions to the
chessboard honest and David start at
that game you first of all you'd never
beat the guy who's got the ultimate
power but I'll also admit I got beat by
David because he was smarter than I was
Stan I appreciate this chat I hope to do
it a lot more often enjoy your work on
television and and let's let's it all
enjoy tonight's double dip thanks for
the call you got Stan Van Gundy again
tonight on Turner starts at 7:00 Eastern
Time for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel - 39 under red
TV for free on BR Live or download the
Rich Eisen show app